in the last video we finished up asking
ourselves what how much do we produce if
the market price if the market
price
is at 45 cents and just going with the
logic that we introduced in the last
video you want to produce as much as
possible to to spread out the fixed
costs but you don't want to produce so
much that the marginal cost is higher
than your marginal revenue and your
marginal revenue is your market price
every unit every incremental unit you're
going to get 45 cents so you want to
look at the quantity where your marginal
revenue the 45 cents is equal to your
marginal cost and we could look at it
over here so if we look at our marginal
revenue so it's 40 let's say 45 cents is
right over there you want to look where
the 45 cents is equal to your marginal
cost and it looks like it is right over
there now we can even see it on our
table when does our marginal cost equal
45 cents it equals that when we produce
eight thousand gallons of our juice when
we produce eight thousand gallons of our
juice now the reason why this is
somewhat interesting is that that point
the amount of revenue that we're getting
per unit our marginal revenue is less
than our total cost per unit our total
cost we're selling each unit at 45 cents
but our total cost for each of those
units is 48 cents on average so this
right over here is our total cost so you
might say look i'm making a loss on
every unit the total amount of revenue
i'm getting is a smaller rectangle over
here it's the quantity times the
marginal revenue per unit so this is the
amount of revenue that i'm getting let
me color it in carefully that is the
amount of revenue that i'm getting while
my costs are this larger rectangle my
quantity my quantity times my my average
total cost per unit and so what i end up
with is if you take that if you take
that revenue and you subtract out that
quantity you end up with a loss of
exactly this much
you end up you are operating in this
situation at a loss
you're operating at a loss when you are
producing 8 000 units at four and you're
getting 45 cents per unit so does it
make sense for you to do this and we can
even figure out the loss you're
producing 8 000 units and you're selling
them for 45 cents a unit and it costs
you 48 cents per unit to produce them on
average when you put all the costs in 48
cents per unit so you are losing 3 cents
per unit
losing
3 cents
three cents per i guess gallon we're
talking about orange juice here and it's
times eight thousand gallons times eight
thousand gallons
means that we are losing we are losing
two hundred and forty dollars eight
thousand times three cents is 24 000
cents which is the same thing as 240
dollars so does it make sense for us to
do this
well one way to think about it let's say
we didn't do it let's say we're just
we're like hey i'm not going to produce
any gallons well then what's going to be
our loss well we're assuming that this
is our fixed cost we've already
committed ourselves to this expenditure
right over here whether we produce
whether we produce no drops of orange
juice we are still going to be spending
a thousand dollars so if we produce
nothing we are guaranteeing ourselves a
weekly loss of a thousand dollars and so
this is at least better than that so by
starting to produce some units we are at
least able to offset some of that loss
and we're spreading out that fixed cost
over more and more and more gallons and
you might say hey well why don't i just
keep producing more and more units why
don't i just why don't i go here maybe i
produce 9 000 units where the marginal
cost all of a sudden is higher than our
marginal revenue and the reason why that
won't make any sense to do is because if
you produce that many units then all of
a sudden each of those incremental units
that you're producing beyond the eight
thousandth you're losing money on those
that eight thousand and first unit the
marginal cost is going to be higher than
the marginal revenue that you're
bringing in on that unit so you're going
to be losing money you're going to start
having you're going to start having a
lower profit than even the negative 240
loss it'll start going you know negative
240 something negative 250 and so forth
and so on so you still don't want to
produce beyond that point and we'll
touch more deeply on it in future videos
but this is this is essentially what
differentiates the short term supply
curve from the long run supply curve in
the in the in the short term we're going
to assume that we have these fixed costs
and so it's just going to make sense to
produce equivalent to our marginal cost
but over the long run over the long run
maybe our fixed our fixed items our
capital our machinery
wears off or maybe the the contract for
my employees wear off and then we have a
different cost structure over the over
the long term but we'll think about that
in another video but the simple answer
is
assuming these really are your fixed
costs you still want to produce as many
units as possible so that your so that
your marginal cost or is equal to your
marginal revenue which in this case is
the market price we are price takers so
it actually is a rational thing to
produce 8 000 units and take a loss on
that and take a 240 dollar per week loss
as opposed to as opposed to just
producing nothing and taking a thousand
dollar per week loss now it might not be
rational once these things have been
worn out your robots and your the
employees contracts it might not be
rational to continue them past their
term and we'll think about that more in
another because obviously we are running
at a loss and this is not necessarily a
good business to be in but now that
we've gotten into the business we might
as well stay in it in order to uh recoup
some of our costs here or at least
spread them out or at least make uh not
have a thousand dollar per week
a loss anyway see you next video